this video is sponsored by cross out a
free to play action game and as a bonus
for registering through our link below
you'll get a selection of three weapons
or a van cabin for free
[Music]
history is a delicate endeavor it tends
to remember those who make a lasting
impact as larger than life figures
defined by their contributions as well
as the effects and ripples that unfold
after the fact it's easy to forget that
many of the people who shaped our world
started out just like everyone else that
to obey their parents for better or
worse they played and argued with their
siblings they got into trouble at school
they struggled to find a direction in
life the Wright brothers were two such
ordinary figures they weren't born into
wealth or power they didn't have clear
goals in life for a long time they
didn't even graduate from high school
because of circumstances beyond their
control but after their first flight on
December the 17th 1903 they set in
motion a series of events and
advancements that have had a profound
effect on the world at first no one
believed the Wright brothers had
developed an aircraft powered by an
engine and controlled by human drivers
yet just 38 years later the Avro
Lancaster the plane that would become
one of the Allies most successful
weapons during World War two rolled off
the assembly line the four flights
became a revolutionary development in
travel diplomacy logistics or warfare it
was the obsession of two brothers fueled
by curiosity and powered by the
influence love and encouragement of an
entire family
it was Wilbur Wright who once said if I
were giving a young man advice as to how
he might succeed in life I would say to
him pick out a good father and mother
and begin life in Ohio to truly
understand Wilbur and Orville Wright
we're going to need to start with their
parents because in another environment
or in another family governed by other
parents it's entirely possible these two
gentlemen would have been uninspired
Church janitors the patriarch of the
Wright family was Milton or as he was
known to his brethren Bishop Wright born
in 1828 he grew up working on his
parents Indiana farm where he practiced
his public speaking skills as he toiled
away in the fields reading every book
that he could find and developing a firm
belief in the evils of slavery it was
also in those fields that the
fifteen-year-old Milton had something of
a religious Epiphany
one that he later explains like this it
was not by forces visions or signs but
by an impression that spoke to the soul
powerfully and abiding Lee
there was no sudden revelation from
great anguish to ecstatic joy but a
sweet peace and joy which I had never
known before
it wasn't until 1847 that he joins the
Church of the United Brethren rising
quickly through the hierarchy in an
organization that recognized his gift
for giving sermons and relating to
people in an unprecedented way he was
eventually made a circuit preacher which
means he traveled from church to church
across the state one of the towns on
this circuit was Hartsville where not
only did he visit the church but he also
saw a wound he had quartered in college
they had separated after he developed a
serious illness but he had never
forgotten her when the church reassigned
Milton to the wild frontier and gold
mining towns of Oregon he asked her to
marry him
she agreed that she would wait for him
to return and if they still felt the
same they were
marry two years later he returned to
Indiana and he married Susan corner the
first and second sons Roulin and Lauren
came along in 1861 and 1862 it was
another five years before Wilbur was
born and after the birth of twins who
died in their infancy Orville was
welcomed into the family in 1871 three
years later the family was completed
with the arrival of a sister Catherine
for their entire lives the siblings
particularly will ver Orville and
Catherine remained incredibly close near
as Catherine who once described their
childhood in terms that would make
anyone envious saying no family ever had
a happier childhood than ours I was
always in a hurry to get home after I
had been away half a day
the daily life of the right siblings was
strict and disciplined but it was also a
warm loving environment with parents who
encouraged their children's individual
talents in some ways Milton was
staunchly conservative but he was also
very progressive in his views on things
like the abolition of slavery and other
social issues he did meet his wife while
she was studying for a literature degree
from Hartsville college and in the mid
19th century that wasn't exactly normal
for women
Milton continued to travel with his
church job and was away from the family
for long periods of time but he made
sure to stay active in their lives he
send them regular letters gave them
complete access to his extensive library
and bought them gifts including ones
that sparked an interest in Wilbur and
Orville that wouldn't truly develop for
many years to come they called it the
bat and it was a toy helicopter that
Milton gave the boys in 1878 it was
based on the designs of French
aeronautical pioneer Alphonse Pernod and
it was essentially a rubber band
attached to a propeller that would send
the toy shooting up into the sky Wilbur
and Orville then eleven and seven years
old respectively attempted to make their
own larger version of the toy and while
they never quite pulled it off
successfully it did kickstart a
fascination with machinery they never
forgot this gift either decades later
they would write about how that one
simple toy that one small gift from a
loving father eventually guided the
course of their entire adult lives their
mother too had a huge impact on their
love of all things mechanical Susan
Wright had grown up working alongside
her father in his carriage shop web she
too nurtured a lifelong love of machines
and gadgets Wilbur and Orville grew up
watching her design and build small
appliances for use around the house they
also played with toys she had built for
them as adults that brothers recognized
the influences that the parents had
although once said we were lucky enough
to grow up in an environment where there
was always much encouragement to
children to pursue intellectual
interests to investigate whatever the
aroused curiosity in a different kind of
environments our curiosity might have
been nipped long before it could have
borne fruit that's not to say everything
was easy because Milton's position in
the church involved so much travel the
whole family often found itself uprooted
as well moving along
mazi established training schools for
those interested in learning the
church's theology at one point Milton
even helped found a seminary College but
all was not well within the church and
in the years after Catherine's birth
schism develops between those who wanted
the church to stay the same as it had
always been and the more liberal-minded
folks who were looking to change the way
the church dealt with things like
parishioners who also wanted to belong
to secret societies like the Freemasons
Milton was on the side of the
Conservatives and he was in the minority
by 1881 he had been removed from his
position as bishop and returned to the
same Indiana Circuit's he had preached
on when he first courted his wife yet
even as a church drama played out on a
national scale with him directly in the
center something far more dramatic was
happening in the right household susan
had been diagnosed with tuberculosis by
this time the precocious boys who had
been captivated by a flying toy we're in
high school Orville was gravitating
towards science and technology he was
known for being equal parts clever and
mischievous yes when he was around those
he didn't know it was almost painfully
shy like many brilliant students he had
trouble applying himself to a curriculum
so instead of going through his required
junior year classes he opted for college
prep courses
unfortunately that disqualified him from
getting a high school degree so he
decided he simply wasn't going to bother
with school anymore
Wilbur didn't graduate high school
either the family moved again before he
could finish
he eventually skipped the end of high
school and went straight into college
prep classes with the hope of going to
Yale and becoming a teacher but fate had
other things in mind we're all Ville was
the shy one who loved practical jokes
Wilbur was confident eloquence and
always level-headed until the winter of
1885 that unfortunate season saw Wilbur
playing ice hockey with a group of
friends when he was hit in the face by a
rogue stick he lost most of his upper
teeth and was house bound for several
weeks the untimely accidents would only
get worse complications from the injury
turned into digestive issues heart
palpitations and long bouts of
depression that made him abandon his
hopes of Yale instead he spent the next
few years of his life caring for
his already old mother until her death
in 1889 now history is a strange thing
interconnected in ways that are nothing
short of bizarre so here's where it's
worth taking an aside the boy who hid
Wilbur was named Oliver crook [ __ ] and
while it's unclear whether it was an
accident or on purpose we can say that
he was known as a neighborhood bully
[ __ ] who was working at a local
drugstore later became addicted to one
of the most typical medicines of the era
cocaine toothache drops the combination
of drugs alcohol and erratic behavior
Sauron committed to an asylum and when
he got out he ended up reading Robert
Louis Stevenson's The Strange Case of
dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
at first he identified with Jekyll
believing his newly and medical degree
was going to help him find a great Kuril
but as his cocaine habit continued he
wrote that he was becoming more like mr.
Hyde Oliver's true descent into darkness
started six years after that 1885
incidents on the ice between 1891 and
1905 it's believed that he killed at
least 16 people starting out with his
fiance's father and including his own
mother father and brother in 1907 the
same time Wilbur and Orville were trying
to get people to take their invention
seriously he was executed for his crimes
[Music]
the passing of a beloved parent spawns a
grief well beyond words and everyone
deals with that grief in their own way
within days of burying Susan Milton was
back at work Wilbur and Orville attacked
work as well embarking on a journey to
start a publishing business and
newspaper well Bert was to serve as the
editor Aaron's Orville as the publisher
so after the death of their mother
Orville and Wilbur set out about
building a new printing press it was
called the Westside news and it wasn't
as much of a familial departure as you
might expect their father had been the
editor of a publication called the
religious telescope and while they were
still in school there - even printed
their own newspaper called the [ __ ]
while he's had honorable beginnings the
idea was that it was going to advertise
a fledgling printing business their
parents quickly put them out of business
when they found out that they intended
to run a column called the inherent
wickedness of schoolchildren with a
tributed to one of their teachers so
after the death of their mother Orville
and Wilbur set about building a new
printing press well it was new to them
anyway it was made from a broken
tombstone parts of an old buggy and
other miscellaneous bits and bobs the
brothers were immensely successful
thanks in part to their prior knowledge
of the industry but also because they
had an immediate injection of regular
business buoyed by a partnership with
the Church of the United Brethren they
expanded their printing house built a
second press and accepted at least one
contract to build a similar press for
another business with commerce booming
the young entrepreneurs began building
themselves as the Wright brothers this
was around the same time a new
transportation craze was sweeping across
the u.s. it was called wheeling and it
came about with the invention of what
was then called the safety bicycle it's
basically the bicycle that we know today
with two wheels of similar size Wilbur
and Orville were both passionate
cyclists regularly going on long trips
and even winning races their mechanical
aptitude allowed them to do what many
people can only dream of
and that's turning their passion into
their livelihood after friends and
fellow cyclists started asking them to
help repairing their bikes
the Wright brothers realized they could
build something better and so they did
in addition to their old printing press
and their new repair business they
started building two models of bikes
each named after early Ohio pioneers the
Van Cleve was their high-end model named
for their great-aunt Mary Van Cleve who
had been the first person to set foot on
the lands that would become Dayton Ohio
they also had a Sinclair model that was
more accessible the Wright brothers were
again successful but it was just one
more stepping stone in their life's
pursuits the next step is the logical
continuation of an adventurous bikers
mindset hopping on your bike heading off
on a grand trip cresting a hill and
speeding downwards well it's a little
bit like flying isn't it now just before
we continue their journey to flight I
want to take a moment to tell you about
today's sponsor cross out the best way
for me to do that is to jump over to the
computer hello everyone in walk ins
across our business a vehicle action
shooter game what you do is everyone
builds their own vehicle this is what I
built let's make some modification
that's ricki release guns let's get rid
of these wheels let's get some armored
tracks on there yeah I think it's pretty
clear that that is a bit of an upgrade
let's get some extra guns yeah I'd say
that's looking pretty good for you guys
you could just take it for a quick test
drive see and then I realize okay well
you can't use these boosters because you
got tracks but let's see how that works
yeah that's quite effective
now there's an absolutely huge chance
and a pasture bill from you sir all
those weapons and stuff that I could
just put on that is just scratching the
surface and now look at all these people
we get to play against loads of
different game types PvP PvE raids all
of that good stuff and it's super easy
to get into I mean look how different
this guy looks to me wow that guy's got
some cool rockets I want some of that
action
oh yes I think I got that kill why don't
you get a kill assist come on I'm
definitely on fire but they seem to be
doing okay
so yeah this is Crossout it's it's just
a huge game so easy to get into so much
fun to be had and look at how all these
vehicles are completely different
these guys are rocket boosters and stuff
and hopper pads and it's crazy it's
crossed out let's get back to the show
so yes that's cross out free-to-play
easy to get into registers I'll link
below and you'll get a selection of
three weapons or a van cabin for free
let's get back to it
[Music]
the Wright brothers were far from the
first people to fly to look down and see
the ground passing beneath their feet
and what had to be an experience both
exhilarating and terrifying even as they
were busy designing and building their
own bicycles the headlines were captured
by news from the burgeoning world of
aeronautics at the time it was all
highly experimental and there were lots
and lots of failures but none captured
the Wright brothers imagination like
that of Otto Lilienthal lilienthal was a
German aeronautical engineer responsible
for developing groundbreaking theories
like the idea that a curved wing shape
would provide more lift than a flat wing
he wasn't just a theorist he designed 16
different versions of gliders and took
them all almost 2,000 flights albeit
brief flights
it was cutting-edge work for the time
that the limitations of gliders became
tragically clear on August the 9th 1896
lilienthal was flying in one of his
monoplane gliders when it was caught by
a sudden gust of wind the nose was
pushed upwards his forward momentum was
stalled and he died the following day
after breaking his spine in the ensuing
crash as newspapers reported on the
death of the aviation pioneer Wilbur
vigil beside his brother Orville had
contracted typhoid fever he was
bedridden for several months and it
wasn't until October that he was lucid
enough to understand what his brother
was telling him about lilienthal's death
and the problems still unresolved the
crash Illustrated just how vital it was
to not only be able to fly but to have
control over that flight that would
allow for control over external factors
like rogue wind gusts while Wilbur had
nursed his brother through is
potentially deadly illness he had
returned to that forgotten interest that
they'd had as children Wilbert headed to
the library to find books on the
principles of flying and when Orville
was once again coherence they agreed it
was a lack of control that had led to
lilienthal's death and that was
something they might be able to work on
as it turns out that timing was
fortuitous the popularity of bicycles
meant more and more companies were
beginning to mass produce them and
smaller businesses like the rides were
being boxed out of the market even
though Orville assured his father they
were doing fine and business was booming
they saw all the writing on the
war so when word got out that the u.s.
government was throwing obscene amounts
of money at the research of manned
flight it became clear which project
deserved their attention it was Wilbur
who came up with the idea of adjusting
the wings of a crafts to capture winds
and guide it leading them to design a
kite with controls that allowed them to
twist the wings it worked exactly like
their plans and Wilbur who hadn't been
able to wait until Orville returned from
a camping trip to try out their kite
hopped on his bike headed out into the
woods and told his brother that cracked
it
anyone who has been to Ohio knows that
it's pretty flat making it an elegance
location to test experimental aircraft
the rights needed another plan so they
reached out to the u.s. weather bureau
and asked for test locations that could
give them elevation wind and preferably
a soft place to land among the
suggestions was Kitty Hawk North
Carolina a village that had a decent
average wind speed high dunes to launch
from thence because the brothers had no
illusions about what they were
attempting sands that would offer a much
more forgiving landing than most other
surfaces so they headed off to Kitty
Hawk and yes their family was
understandably worried so worried in
fact that their father made them promise
to never ever both get into the plane at
the same time a crash in which he lost
one son would have been tragic but
losing both sons would have been too
much to bear the brothers ultimately
kept their promise only taking one
single flight together in 1910 their
first biplane lifted off in 1900s but
this attempt was more of a kites than a
manned Collider flying his unmanned
allowed them to make observations and
adjustments and in 1901 the new and
improved model was ready to go for miles
outside of Kitty Hawk the brothers flew
between 50 and 100 glides but still
weren't happy with the progress they had
made in the area of control realizing
they needed more information the
brothers constructed their own wind
tunnel to test various shapes sizes and
wing configurations their third glider
really was spectacular and they flew
hundreds of man's flights built a
control system and added a rudder
finally it was time to throttle up on
the power the Wright brothers recruited
a machinist who worked with them on
their bicycle as a man by the name of
Charles Taylor together they built a
combustion engine and propeller system
and it was this first powered manned
fully controlled flight that changed the
world the first flights lasted less than
a minute but by 1905 they had perfected
not only their technology but their own
skills to the points where they could
stay in the air for a maximum of 39
minutes it wasn't long before they
realized that solving those first
mysteries of flight wouldn't even be the
most difficult challenge they would face
the brothers had trouble convincing
people that these flights were even
possible
the brothers set off in a series of
demonstrations securing funding from the
USR
me and a group of French investors for
continued experiments by 1908 the US
Army offered them $25,000 for a plane
that could fly at at least 40 miles per
hour and carry a passenger as well as a
pilot the brothers got to work
the Wright brothers success came fast
and in the following years Wilbur flew
demonstrations for audiences across
Europe and America by 1909 they
incorporated the right company and the
right exhibition company came a year
later innovation and hands-on
development soon gave way to other
matters one that had become more
pressing Wilbur was soon more occupied
with protecting their intellectual
property and the rights to their
invention involving the company in
scores of lawsuits and much later they
would be accused of delaying the
advancement of the very science that
they had worked so hard on only three
years after the establishment of the
right company on May the 30th 1912
Robert suddenly passed away he had
contracted typhoid fever and was
exhausted by the toll the company had
taken on him
Orville only remains with the firm they
had established for another three years
he sold his portion of the company to
investors not long after on April the
3rd 1917 Milton Wright died at his home
peacefully at the age of 88 Orville
continued to remain active in the fields
consulting with government throughout
the world wars and serving with
organizations like the National Advisory
Committee for Aeronautics and the Daniel
and Florence Guggenheim fund for the
promotion of aeronautics
it wasn't the preferred life of the
brother who had once been known as the
shy practical joker and for much of his
remaining years he chose to spend the
majority of his time with friends and
family in Ohio or in his Ontario
vacation home
Orville also embarked on a long-standing
feud with the Smithsonian who had
publicly claimed in 1914 that it wasn't
the Wright brothers after all who had
conducted the first manned flight but
rather Samuel Langley determines not to
allow their achievements to be
overshadowed Orville fought not just for
the retraction that came in 1928 but for
an apology one that wasn't given until
1942 six years later on January the 27th
1948 Orville had a heart attack he died
three days later on January the 30th by
then he had seen incredible things their
invention beginning with their first
experiments in controlling a kite over
their sleepy hometown had taken on a
life of its own by his final decade the
Bombers of World War two
were changing history yet again for all
the impact Susan Wright had on her
children she never lived to see them
change the world or even fly Milton did
though and he liked his children
eventually took to the skies he was 82
years old when he got into a plane for
the first and only time with Orville
behind the controls as they took off he
shouted from the passenger seat higher
Orville higher and they went higher so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe also do check out our
fantastic sponsor cross out who I will
link to below and thank you for watching
[Music]